[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
how's everyone doing in San Francisco
today
yeah
oh it's lovely to be here we're big
we're Big League of Legends fans that's
why we're here
is everyone coming tomorrow
[Applause]
who's going to win Dom well I think t1's
gonna win aren't they
no that's a lot of people saying no
we're gonna we're gonna at some point
get questions from the audience to talk
about what we think is going to go on
tomorrow but um this is our first world
isn't it bills this is it first World
San Francisco uh it's a it's a nice Town
isn't it fantastic Town San Francisco
who's who's from here who's from San
Francisco yes yes and yes everyone else
has come in for the world
yeah where'd you come from
Florida wow Billy and I went for lunch
today and we were surrounded by people
who were either streamers or maybe even
Pro Gamers just hanging out so it's like
the whole of San Francisco's been taken
over by League of Legends right now I
love it I love it we we should talk
about our journey with League of Legends
build go on Taylor's how did it start on
maybe maybe this is the same for a lot
of other people that are playing League
of Legends right now but during covid
I I was not working like a lot of people
and I was looking for something to do on
my computer outside of just like writing
on it and and and doing admin
and I found a game that was free to play
free to download I went to a place
called Encinitas in California
played it for about four days on my own
and was really confused really confused
didn't know what was going on getting
killed a lot and then I got in touch
with you and said you should play this
game the first thing you've got to know
about drama is it doesn't like to spend
money no very Thrifty he'll never buy
you a gift he never buys you lunch no
point and then you heard I've bought him
some skins actually I've wanted some
skins
I don't think you did really I bought
you skins well actually I didn't buy
your skins I got you unlimited free
skins from Ryan oh sorry sorry yeah
exactly
but yeah so he he got this game and uh I
think Dom thought I was only going to
play it for a couple of times and give
it up but it grabs you doesn't it hey
who's your favorite Champion hey Madina
Billy you have you've split the audience
I don't care right down the middle I'm a
big fan of heimeninger Might well let me
check the audience temperature here my
favorite Champion is Lux
ladies love locks I'm quite connected to
my family it's not your favorite right
now though no my favorite right now
which is a slight kind of off meta
Champion is Yorick does anyone play
Yorick
oh the boys love Yorick the maiden yes I
love the maiden
I just I just think Yorick is such a
kind of OP champion because if you've
got his ultimate cracking off and the
Maiden doesn't die that means that your
ultimate is going on at all times as
opposed to just like Lux she goes one
one time at it let's get back to hey
Madina yeah
right
where's my dog
[Laughter]
uh now what about I was gonna actually
this on the plane but I thought I'd wait
what is the champion that you've played
that you think you're the worst at that
you absolutely [ __ ] the bed at so
because it's a hard game isn't it it is
difficult here's the great thing we I've
probably been playing for what now a
year and a half yeah almost two years
yeah about a year and a half I know none
of the characters names I don't know
what any of them do a nightmare skins
have a hard time with skins because as
soon as something puts their skin on I
don't know who the champion is yeah
yeah very often we'll be playing and
I'll say right come on let's quickly get
the rift Herald and Billy will go which
one's the rift Herald
after a year and a half yeah I mean but
so most of the time when we talk about
Champions I have to say some of the
things that they do
to be able to tell you who I was playing
yeah so who's the one that you who's the
guy then ultimate his ultimate is he he
gets a kind of triangle from him and he
can fire like three or four shots oh Jin
gin and tonic Jen Jen I've I've found
Jen really difficult I couldn't Legion
yeah yeah that is that is a tricky one
after and Nigel play gin and played him
quite well quite well yeah I think the
champion that I struggle with the most
I've only played once and he's so tricky
he's Leasing
I think because unless you unless you or
your mates are putting Wards up
no but our friend Jake did an insect
when we were playing last time where he
the kick oh yeah uh enemy did he kick it
into the turret or into the into the
team
[Music]
all these terms who is the most
difficult Champion to play
Lee sin
one at a time guys
you me the little cat the cat
do you you want red to hear me
I think I think they're messing with us
what happened right because I I've I've
never played you mate but see when you
see when see when you jump on someone
and like you're playing Jimmy then do
you just take a break
does it do you
you just go get a couple of drinks yeah
you don't have to worry about moving
that would be great for you because you
do sometimes Billy's been playing for a
year and a half and I think two weeks
ago he unlocked his camera
once a big battle starts I lock it up
again because it flies all over the
place
it's not easy I've known Billy I've
known Billy yeah yeah space bar space
bar is your friend that's right
but I hate to be rubbish at it but the
only I've known Billy for 20 years and
the only legit argument fight that we've
had was playing League of Legends and
this is what happened right you lulu at
the time I think you were literally
support yeah so Billy was going to we
were in bottom Lane I'd already gone
back to the shot and I said come on
let's go back to shot and Billy's like
no I'm okay I'll stay here for a second
like okay so I was back at the shop and
I was watching Billy and he started to
teleport not quite being protected by
his turret and I said don't teleport
there because the enemy Champion's just
gonna walk up and zap you and he's like
no I'm okay and then Morgana came in
yeah and Zapped you yeah and killed you
yep and I said oh Billy you shouldn't be
teleporting that and you said no it was
Morgana she froze me and I said no no I
was watching and you were teleporting
from the wrong place that's not the way
you said you said it like this
yeah like I had my game face on my game
voice I'd never heard them go like that
ever
and I've done some terrible thing yeah
you you've you've uh you stole a couple
of my girlfriends before and I wasn't
yeah but it didn't seem to bother it's
okay that's what happens between friends
but I get killed under the tower and he
went crazy that is honestly the only
time we've ever fallen out it's true and
then it was awful then because then we
had another like half an hour left of
the game and and there's like a bad
smell in the room you know and like
everyone knew it and Billy was saying
stuff like have you had a bad day or
something and I said no no I'm fine he
said well why would you shout at me like
that and I'm like oh can we just finish
the game and we didn't we didn't play
well did we
yeah now but it's hey it's always fun
it's always in the back of your mind
League of Legends as well what about
this what about this is a question
because this is something for people in
the audience think about as well right
if you could click your fingers yeah and
be brilliant at any champion in the game
who would you pick
good
don't say Yumi
I would you know who I'd love to be
great at Kaiser oh yeah lovely Kaiser
I'd love to be able to Dart around you
know people who are great at Kaiser I
would I would yeah that would be who I
would choose also Billy is quite a
Whimsical human well you may and one of
the great things about Kaiser I don't
know if you guys know this lovely piece
of trivia about kosa is uh she's able to
just drop a frog down on the floor
yeah at any given point she's like
there's a frog and it sometimes sucks it
back up again yeah sometimes Billy will
be like oh I've got a free second here
hang on let me just drop an amphibian on
the floor there
and then pick it up really quickly and
the other thing I like about case k says
you can put her helmet on yeah does that
do innocent
it just looks cool right
and that will only pick a skin that has
a cool helmet yeah he played a Kaiser
the other day and unfortunately the
helmet was a tiara and Billy's like oh
we [ __ ] lost this game
because he had a tiara hey can I tell
you I'd like to be an expert at if I
could clip Dom let me ask you come on if
you could click your fingers and be an
expert at any champion in League of
Legends yeah who would that be well you
mean any expert any Champion any
Champion full-on expert you know I'd go
Twisted Fate would you really yeah a
light Twisted Fate there's a lot about
Twisted Fate he's got a big kick because
obviously he's got different playing
cards oh yeah things and his ultimate is
a teleport to other places on the map
right so he can jump into any fight that
he wants to it's a difficult Champion
though he looks good and all done
between family and busy life I've got
enough to worry about oh yeah I need the
Peace of Mind of identity protection but
how do I know what protection I need
well you've got to check out Allstate
identity protection the best of identity
protection from a brand you can trust
the internet knows a lot about you but
it doesn't have to and with Allstate
digital footprint see a list of your
online accounts track where you've been
online learn how companies are using
your data if your personal information
has been exposed in a data breach get
tips to proactively protect your privacy
and identity and All-State identity
protection even includes dark web
monitoring monitoring with AI and human
Source intelligence providing an extra
layer of detection with AIP they
reimburse up to a million dollars for
out-of-pocket expenses lost wages legal
fees they'll also cover money stolen
from your bank account
401ks hses and tax returns not only will
all state monitor to help keep you safe
but should identity theft ever occur
their us-based customer care identity
Specialists provide expert support 24 7
365 days with an industry leading in 98
satisfaction score that's almost perfect
it's only two percent away think the
identity protection your bank provides
is enough well think again the reality
is that most financial institutions Act
only after fraud occurs rather than
preventing it having comprehensive
monitoring and coverage from AIP will
help make sure that you can stop
identity thieves in their tracks before
any major damage is done plus EIP can
even monitor your social media to ensure
no one takes over your account oh lovely
fantastic yeah what I love about
Allstate identity protection is the
Peace of Mind knowing Allstate protects
my digital footprint I'm online I do my
thing online but I don't know what
happens to me when I'm offline and
people say oh don't monaghan's doing
this and that I have people on Instagram
pretending to be me they're not me
Millie they're other people and what I
like about this storm is it's so easy to
use I mean even for me so when you think
identity protection think all state
identity protection to find out if
you're an employer offers all state
identity protection head to aip.com
onion if not get a 30 day free trial at
aip.com onion and now one last time
aip.com
hey we just met Tyler on were you guys
here uh seeing what channel Amazon too
what a lovely chap
what a lovely fella
Billy was giving him some advice about
the gym because he thought he'd slightly
lost a little bit of form so and I'm
bulking at the moment
yeah
right
yeah yeah Billy's bulking right now I'm
cutting and we're gonna meet in the
middle you're gonna end up cutting and
I'm gonna start bulking we'll do that in
a couple of weeks create the perfect
perfect human
um is everyone very excited about
tomorrow
hey is everyone coming or are you all
just kind of hanging are you loitering
with intent
so everyone got tickets you've got
tickets
no
is there an opportunity to like win
tickets it's like a competition also
really
because Billy Billy's sister got in
touch in this morning and said that the
tickets are going for 900 right now
well this is what we'll do right because
Billy and I have become quite close with
Faker haven't we yeah
good good friend of ours Baker very good
friend because we both speak uh fluent
Korean don't we yes we do John after
this we probably it looks like we need
probably something like 40 or 50 tickets
or something
we'll have a chat with Faker because he
won't he won't play unless uh everyone
you know uh
Billy and I were wondering today like
what what do we think those two teams
are doing today like are they sat
getting hand massages or something uh
hang on you man in the white nose he's
been speaking to him
of Lord of the Rings yeah yeah well well
why wouldn't it right why wouldn't they
yeah I mean how else would you spend
your day it's a great it's a great way
to Prime yourself isn't it I wonder if
fake has seen Lord of the Rings it would
be amazing to me have you not asked them
yet no I've not asked him I don't I
don't want to you know be that intrusive
I hear you dumb but he is do you guys
all know who uh Leona Leo Messi is
fakers like the Leo Messi of uh of
League of Legends didn't you yeah yeah
um also I'm wearing Team Liquid pants
shout out to Team Liquid
there you are in your team liquid [ __ ]
over there there you go I did a I did a
little coaching session I I wasn't
coaching team again because I felt like
they probably knew enough so instead
they coached me and then I played with
whippo is that right is that
and I think he was something like
1607 in the game just destroying through
the jungle as hecarim by the way
you would be an incredible hacker I'll
have a go at that I've never gone the
horse you know the guy oh yeah you'd be
brilliant I would love that
yeah well when I when I played he was he
was hecarim in the jungle I think he was
just messing about you know but he was
he was incredible
what do you think's gonna happen
tomorrow who do you think's gonna win
John I'll tell you I'll tell you who
mate look at your crystal balls hey
I'm not sure I'm looking for I think
it's going to be a great day I'm really
oh it's so exciting I mean the energy
out here is insane the energy in there's
gonna be Bonkers I know it's got a bit
crazy and I tell you something we've got
a guest we've got a guest on we'll bring
on our guests we've got a fantastic
guess and if someone would have an idea
of who may win tomorrow oh yeah he might
yeah because we'll get the head of
Esports for uh Riot games Mr uh Chris
grullian here he is
he knows ever everything about League of
Legends and e-games Esports
and there's also a great friend of Faker
like us
how's it going Chris can you confirm or
deny that Faker is going to come out
here and give this crowd 50 or 60
tickets in the next three or four
minutes I think I think that's right
brilliant oh
he's on his way oh he's starting to Riot
you a riot there's a ban Yumi sign over
there love that fine you me brilliant
is it any anyone play Teemo out there
because Teemo lives in my heart yo bro
I love that teeny tiny Teemo oh he's so
cute there's a big team we'll play on
there everybody just pointed at that guy
there yeah I love Teemo manko won
forever all right Chris well let's get
into it so
what can you tell us about first of all
how you got involved with Esports in
general and specifically League of
Legends right and then we can get a
little bit more into the finals yeah I
think first of all the stage has just
gotten objectively less funny and
interesting with me no no it's got more
expert more more professional now that's
what we want well there's nothing worse
than being in front of an entire crowd
who knows more about League of Legends
than I do so I am absolutely going to
screw something up we might throw out
the mic for a q a in a sec if people
want to ask questions so that's a good
idea but Chris please yeah so I uh I
started playing League of Legends in
2012. uh long before I worked at Riot I
started working at riot in 2017. who did
you start as who was your Champion that
you started so I have always been a
support mean uh so uh big yeah there we
go
uh big Lulu fan oh yeah
do you like Yumi uh no so uh
no one likes you hear me evidently no no
like Sumi
um I love Lulu I'm going to turn you
into a rabbit yeah yeah that's amazing
right make everybody pop up I love it I
I started it right in 2017 uh I worked
on the LCS for a very long time I used
to be the commissioner of the LCS uh and
then recently joined uh love the woo uh
behind me thank you uh and then uh
recently joined the global team so now I
work on events like Worlds the bubble
team the global team oh I just confuse
them so and it's a I mean it's obviously
a huge operation that goes on everything
leads to this moment for you guys so how
much more is has the work at Riot ramped
up in the last kind of month or so yeah
I mean this is uh this is all hands on
deck for us so every region every person
we even have folks here who work
primarily on valorant which is another
one of our games who show up to help and
and make sure that we pull off the event
and uh give a great show to all the
people who show up all the people who
watch from home but that's a it's a it's
a big deal how how does it how did it
even start like not video games but how
did people start having World
Championships on a video game like when
was that so uh Starcraft was really big
before before League of Legends was big
right but but back in 2011 at a dream
hack in Sweden we had the first World
Championship uh what was that what was
the prize do you know oh God I think it
was like uh 250 Grand maybe 25 oh still
wow that's all right
um it was it was won by a team from EU
only time yeah no no cheers for EU
um yeah there you go oh yeah we like
those European teams yeah
uh and and since then it you know I
think the live audience in 2011 was like
200 people they they sat on folding
chairs behind the players and just kind
of watched over their shoulders yeah and
then after that everything got big we
were at the Galen Center in LA in 2012.
since then we've been all over the world
China Europe Korea back here so feels
good to bring worlds back to North
America yeah absolutely yes and what
what's your take on it being so big in
Asia and the Asian teams being so
dominant what's what's the thought
process behind that
I mean if I knew that I think the the
North American teams would be would be a
lot better I mean they obviously they
play a lot more right so
I think if you
Esports is really ingrained in Korean
culture so is it really yeah it is uh
it's like a really accepted path for
people and they're like hey I'm gonna be
a professional video game player people
are like yeah that makes sense and
outside of League what what are the
other games historically that have been
big I don't know that there are any
other games good point good point let's
stay on stay on target yeah uh but uh
games like Starcraft uh we're super big
in Korea right
um there's a handful of other Esports
out there that we don't have to talk
about yeah sure sure shout out to FIFA
um because I mean it is a dominant we've
got two teams from Asia in the finals
right from Korea yeah from Korea and
it's T1 would be would be the number one
seeded team right correct no well they
were so they were the number two seed
from from the from Korea from the lck
right and then DRX was the number four
seed from Korea so so team one obviously
favorites tomorrow I think it depends
who you ask I mean the crowd had some
difference yeah it was 50 50.
love it
it's just a noise just a noise really
um brilliant you guys know that you guys
know the story though right so you have
Faker who's the goat who's lifted the
trophy three times yeah killable Demon
King all right and then on that then on
the other side you have Deft uh who is
Gotta Give the pause he's he's looking
for his first trophy but the two of them
went to the same High School in in Korea
oh so they don't know each other well
yeah wow does it feel like Faker could
walk into Riot's head office and slap
someone in the face and get away with it
yeah I think maybe right so I'm gonna no
comment that sure oh yeah I mean that
means it's probably happened yeah well
you know
what do you think the chances are that
we can meet him is he is he so like on
stage today probably close to zero but
yeah if he wins yeah if you I mean if
you and we get a couple of tequila shots
next you guys are hanging around
tomorrow and again I'm sure we could I
mean let's let's make that happen
because I'm a lox Main and I think
there's a couple of things that I could
just kind of you know people don't do
that yeah Savory you know just be
patient Faker maybe you can shoot at
them shouted at me oh sorry about that
that's all right so there's that bad
smell around again hey see
um
well it's going to be very exciting this
is obviously the first world that I've
ever been to how many people are going
to be in that Stadium tomorrow
15 000 and change
so how
for someone who maybe listen to this and
doesn't know how does it work tomorrow
how many games who gets to win yeah so
uh tomorrow series is a best of five so
the first team that wins three games
well first to three first to three we
are hoping for a full five yeah
so right before right before the fifth
game uh we have a tradition in League of
Legends Esports we play a song called
silver scrapes there we go
so the whole the whole Arena will go
absolutely ape [ __ ] uh everyone will
have their phones out with the
flashlights on you'll kind of get a
little bit of the like yeah the concert
five and then yeah everyone kind of
sings along even though the song has no
words
well I hope that does happen and wasn't
it tradition where if it went to game
five they picked the same champion on
each on either side of the team or does
that not happen anymore I think you made
that up oh really yeah you totally made
that up you've made up a lot of things
today sometimes lucid dream and it might
have been a lucid dream we met someone
from a Disney World today and Dom kept
asking us things about is it true that
if you see what was it you said yeah I
thought all these things were true I
said is it not true that if you go over
to people dressed as Toy Story
characters in Disney World and you say
Andy's coming they have to fall on the
floor and she said no that's [ __ ]
that's not true and then I said Is it
true that if it's your birthday and you
go up to a churro salesman and show them
your ID and can prove it's your birthday
you get a free churro that's shy as well
so so you've got a lot of non-truths and
then she told us a really uh quite
traumatic story about a man trying to
steal Snow White he got very drunk
apparently yeah well probably we'll
probably just leave that for an off-air
conversation yeah I think that's right
um outside of obviously the the fact
that you can walk around and say I'm
part of the world champion team is there
a cash money prize do they get to keep
the Summoners cup or just lift it so
they get to lift it and this is a heavy
cop right there's a heavy Cup this year
it's new uh it was produced by by
Tiffany's uh can Billy and I get a
chance to uh take a look maybe polish it
yeah maybe
drink it they'll get there they get
their names engraved on the trophy is
that right they win a pretty nice prize
for uh and then they get champions in
this Champion skins in the game uh that
they get to help create and that are
reflective of them so they've gotten
much cooler over the years now their
signature is in the recall animation
they get to help decide what that recall
animation will look like I can they can
help pick pick the champion the skin
will be on as long as they have played
that champion at Worlds wow so they
become ingrained in the game itself
which is obviously and it is super cool
when you see them then on stage playing
their own skin yeah and they do do that
you've seen them wow that's wicked
here's a question Tom if you won and you
had to get your own skin but it was
based on a movie what movie skin would
you get for your Champion that was quite
tough I've just thought of it right now
go
I would get Twisted Fate but I'd dress
him up like Neo in The Matrix
lovely the long black jacket
and the black oh come on that's a good
idea no that's really good I'll speak to
Keanu Keanu and I are quite tight yeah
yeah
um or what was it oh so Billy and I were
talking before you came on stage
who do you think you play
the best at if someone said you have to
play A League of Legends champion to
save your life who would you pick and
what Champion have you played that
you've really struggled at so uh Zyra is
the the champion I would play to save my
life the plant woman anybody who has
ever been low ELO so I must I'm silver
on a good day congrats
are you so me too me too so you know you
know that going in as a silver support
that your your ADC is probably brain
dead
um right so uh you need to win the game
by yourself or else you have no shots
why is the ADC not good at Silver level
well your ADC is bad the opponent's ADC
might as well play play professionally
yeah that's right they know that's how
it goes they know so I xyro will let you
desira you can carry with so you don't
you don't need your ADC if they're good
bonus if they suck you can still kill
people and I love that that Dragon
sorceress skin
that's good okay and what Champion have
you played where you're just like oh my
God I'm not playing this person I mean
pretty much every other support Champion
um which is why I'm still in silver I
think uh I desperately want to be really
good at thresh uh and I'm not
so like I can hit a hook uh I can
sometimes get a Flay sometimes someone
actually clicks on the lantern but
you're not you're it's it's not pretty
but you've got a good thresh storage
remember ah again I'm so bad at this
game but I love it
and then one of our friends was threats
playing thresh and I didn't know about
the Lantern and I'm like why is this
thing always there oh no it wasn't a
friend actually it was just someone
stranger and it was someone who was
really nice and they wrote you know if
you grab that land and look I can save
you
it changed my life
it was br oh God I do I can't believe
how bad I am at this game and then can
you please tell him about the the most
toxic
um thing that someone typed in there's
been quite a few I I got I got someone
who said please never play this game
again
is that just a normal
and
get rid of your computer that one
easy
I do if I'm if I'm having a terrible
they've come for your bills they've come
for you Just Surrender he's here
um if I'm having a real stinker of a
game and the enemy team is giving me
hassle I'll just write in the comments
I'm fake
just to get on their nerves
um I've got riot in my Summoner name ah
so I I don't I don't have the benefit of
being toxic in game so I just yell at my
monitor yeah
um because then I at least I can get the
anger out and I do it in a way that
doesn't either show up on Reddit or get
me fired yeah it makes sense well we are
definitely part of the narrative that
he's not in any way toxic we Billy and I
try and say nice things apart from that
time where you and I had a fight
um we tried we try and say nice things
to people keep it pretty mellow
obviously that's an ongoing thing with
Riot that you're exploring but moving
into the future with with this game what
are the things that that you guys at
Riot are trying to evolve change improve
on make better bathroom Champions
obviously yeah I mean what a big
question that hey I'm here for the big
questions I'm telling you
um
so I'll give you the big answer
everything right so on the on the game
side I don't work on the game side I
don't work on the balance Team all the
all those fun disclaimers
um you know when you talk to them they
want to they want more people to play
they want more people to have more fun
right so yeah that that goes from
Champion design that goes from game
modes right there they're working
through all that stuff I think season 13
which will start to get patch notes on
soon uh is gonna be super cool not to
Hype anybody up
um on the Esports side
um I know that they talked about it at
the media night last night we've got new
formats coming next year for worlds and
MSI uh we're always trying to make
regional competition more fun so if
there are any LCS fans uh out in the
crowd right they're doing they're doing
great work yeah so yeah I mean it is a
it is a really fluffy shitty non-answer
uh but I love the fluff yeah this is
this is not the place for Riot spoilers
unfortunately oh good and obviously you
make you make valorent as well would
there would there be any I mean I know
that like zerry was kind of an almost
kind of crossover character for but
would there be any kind of legit
crossover from Like A League of Legends
champion that could move over to that
game or a Valor over to
I think someone is real if they made one
yeah I don't I don't hang around with
the Valor and design team a lot to
figure out where their head is on right
but I think uh a champion you could see
in both games would be brilliant yeah I
mean I feel like we have Champ like a
felios with the with all the guns yeah
which I heard you guys talking about
before like yeah like a gin being able
to pop out from uh from behind a wall
and just kind of start firing shots down
so yeah man that that stuff could all be
cool game designers now yeah that would
be very cool obviously everyone out
there has seen Arcane right which
what what an unbelievable show
absolutely love it can't wait for the
second season that whole evolution of
powder and things
well shall I just go there I've got any
questions approach about anything you
can ask Don Monahan you can ask Chris
you can ask me oh hang on I'll our
friends I think he's running down is
someone oh there's someone coming down
with a microphone
just talk him I feel yourself just about
to start a song
Killing Me Softly while we wait
we got how many how many of these
figures are out there do you know oh I
have no idea because I mean they're
making a xyro one but it's supposed to
oh
yeah For You especially here's a here's
the question right down the front here I
got a question hang on a second what's
your name and where'd you come from
um says Carolina so
it's time so he's got it
controversial much like you I'm
expecting that maybe he'll try to
squeeze Ari into a uh into champ select
tomorrow because I don't think he's
played Ari yet has he no so let's see if
he can squeeze it in I think if he does
the whole place will go nuts but I
unfortunately don't get to make those
decisions I would love to see the faker
Ari skin though just if anyone from the
game design team is watching that is
Esports approved well as fake have been
hinting at wanting to do an Irish skin
for a long time what's the story behind
it has long been a rumor that Riot said
that he could not do one I actually
don't know if that's true or not but uh
I too sexy
I do think Ari might be the sexiest
champion in the game well that's all I
thought you meant Faker well Faker as
well I mean Baker is too damn Baker and
Ari together woo or Misfortune my
goodness
[Music]
okay anyway another question down the
front there Tom down the front what's
your name sir and where'd you come from
hello hello Sebastian I'm from Orlando
Florida nice what's up Sebastian am I
what are you guys's favorite skin
my all-time favorite skin is dark Cosmic
locks
lovely and there's a great animation in
dark Cosmic looks where she's like
fighting Stars at the at the start it
kind of looks like she's she's doing
something a little distracting sometimes
the enemy team is like whoa she's
actually trying to fight us what about
you bills my favorite and I don't know
if it's called this but it's the Mars
attack Heimerdinger
oh yeah with his brain and his brains on
the outside it's not it's not is he not
cut it's not called Mars Attacks is it
what is it called
hold on hold on you've got a microphone
you can see it alien Vader Heimerdinger
alien invader
I I genuinely think you play like 10
better in that skin only 10 15
better I'm looking forward to that is it
space Groove uh Teemo skin that just
came out
does anyone does anyone watch Manco do
you know Manco one who plays Teemo a lot
that even that guy who plays Teemo a lot
doesn't even know Manco one is I think
you made him up too he's from he's yeah
he's he's from somewhere in the South
right
he's like a good old kind of Southern
boy funny super positive
I wanted him to be here are there any
more are there any more questions here's
an old question your man in white what's
your name and where'd you come from I
didn't get my skin Oh yes I'm sorry
Chris sorry you've got excited the only
correct answer is is mukau Alistar right
but but with the pink chroma oh yeah
that's the right answer and then you
stay in lean the whole time just playing
the cowbell until people start telling
you even your own teammates hey dude you
have to stop this is so annoying and
then you do it twice as much nice that's
right ah friend uh Andrew and Andrew
played the uh he does the all the time
also because I've just started playing
Yorick meow Rick is really cool he
throws the cats he throws cats at people
brilliant who doesn't want to see that
okay sir what's your name and where'd
you come from my name is Ali I was born
and raised here in the Bay Area and my
question was do you guys have any plans
on doing a World Cup level event
internationally
that's a good question so
um no no I'm just kidding um so uh we're
we always look we always look at that
stuff right my big fear candidly that's
not a riot response it's just a Chris
Greely response my big fear is that all
that turns into is the LPL and the lck
which is like kind of all worlds is
right now anyway but if you think about
Europe then you're taking all the best
players in Europe who are all from
different European countries and sending
them back to play with their countries
so you're like you're generally making
those teams weaker
um I I think I think as we look at it we
think about how do you take baby steps
right maybe you do it in the Americas
and you have U.S and Canada and a bunch
of countries in latam and Brazil
um that that could be super cool and
then we can sort of see how that goes
but no no hard plans for 23 I think the
closest thing you get uh are the ersl's
in Europe which I think are I don't like
say anything nice about about the LEC
but uh generally pretty pretty
compelling like watching Spain and
France play every year and people
getting all hyped up about that's pretty
cool so we love that energy we love the
nationalism we love you know when JoJo
came out uh in spring finals wrapped in
an American flag like whole place went
nuts that's good [ __ ] and we want to and
like biofrost did it when we were up in
Toronto in 2016 came out with the
Canadian flag I know that uh
um Vulcan came out wearing wearing a
flag at Worlds too there's like there's
like a lot of really good pieces where
people can get hype and get behind it we
want to find a way to harness that we
just want to do it in a way that just
doesn't feel like we're watching a
repeat of the Asian Games or a repeat of
worlds
great answer Billy I think at some point
in 2023 you and I should turn pro I
think yeah I think maybe like Mark March
or April let's not let's not say January
February that's a bit too hard March or
April March or April you will see me and
Dawn we'll be we'll be foreign
we'll be here and we'll be like what's
up fake that makes sense because worlds
won't be here next year so it does make
oh it's a shame yeah where it where is
world's next year I don't think we've
announced that yet oh okay announce it
right here on the Friendship exclusive
it's gonna be I can announce that it
will not be in North America Next there
you go
Glasgow Scotland yes
you can all stay at Billy's house he's
got a massive Castle you'll love it
[Music]
so be amazing
there's a question right here so oh
you're the Teemo player yeah what's up
dude what's your name and where'd you
come from
there's a there's a Ray LaMontagne song
where he mentions Spokane Washington uh
Jolene incredible song anyway I digress
yeah it's a great song I was just
wondering I know Brazil's getting a very
close player player base as the same as
n a do you think they might become a
major region in the next few years or
another region that might be become a
major region Scotland yes Scotland
that's actually the next one we're
looking at I think uh there are uh
there's a there's a bunch of factors as
we figure out like because really the
question is how many world slots do they
get
um so I mean Brazil's still at one uh
there may be a world where as we start
to mess around with that and they get
more competitive player base keeps
growing viewership grows that there's a
world to to start to shift those slots
around but I I don't think that there
are plans to do that soon but they're
Brazil's been great like uh I don't know
if you watch them in play-ins right the
uh like the bicep Flex was pretty dope
right so uh they have an incredibly
rabid fan base even when they go out and
play and their viewership grows year
over year CB law uh has is just a really
exciting leak to watch so we'll we'll
keep an eye on them and try to figure
out how how we do them Justice it's a
it's a very competitive country in all
sports isn't it Brazil MMA soccer
volleyball anything they play Esports
obviously they're big on I was just
thinking if you had it all professional
Scottish team
playing in the worlds and maybe in that
particular piece of you know the game
like this in the laning phase and it's a
little bit boring you could just tilt
the camera down because the Scott
Scotsman don't wear anything under the
Kilt nothing not a thing and then you
could just you know drag the camera
across on it slowly
the goal is to bring viewership to zero
I think yeah
and then you go oh there's been a kill
and you go back up again I'm just just
put I'm just throwing out diamonds just
throwing out diamonds I think that's
another question down the front now Tom
hello
what's your name and where'd you come
from
hi sweet
[Music]
of the ring so if you were going to pick
a League champion to be the 10th member
of the fellowship who would you pick
what an amazing question good question
Tom we need to figure this out yeah well
what let's do what are we missing in the
fellowship we've got a we're gone
um
you me just jump in from one to the
other I don't know if your music
I think Misfortune fits in quite well in
the fellowship you know that's the thing
about the fellowships it's a great group
of people no strong feminine energy
we're looking for some strong
yeah that's a good question so
you know
Ash Ash Ash Ash is a great show Ash fits
in nice what do you think Legolas to get
pissed off definitely
he's like I'll get the bow and arrow
here yeah yeah but you know like Kaiser
would look so weird yeah what about
another do you know what I mean hanging
out in the shadows and then she comes
out
with the hurricanes and stuff that's a
great question I think it would need to
be Ash wouldn't it I think Ash is the
most on brand
[Applause]
[Music]
who looks locks oh yeah Lux is brilliant
szechwani do you know sichuani no
sichuani's been played a lot in in the
competition
is it like a large guinea pig yes I mean
it's a large guinea pig it feels like a
large guinea pig right okay she's like a
snow Warrior kind of classic yeah on a
snow guinea pig and she's got
she's got what I would refer to as a
bombing knocker a big oh yeah she can't
jump off that thing can she oh no on the
game at least no right okay hey that's a
fantastic question yeah another question
was specifically not for me but if you
pick Twisted Fate the movies last about
15 minutes
right
just jumps and jumps yeah jumps in jumps
out jumps in waits for the cool down and
then pops right back out right right
into the Lake of Fire and you're all
done I love that Billy and Dom eat the
world well we have a regular segment on
the show where we eat the world Billy
and Dom eat the world let's see the
world William I'm gonna pass these over
to you thank you probably mine and
Billy's favorite snack of all time which
is sour gummy sweeties
which if you if you want we'll we'll
come over and hand some up there's only
a couple of bags we said no you don't
Chris don't want to share normally we
get our guest on the podcast to bring
something uh from the childhood or a
food from the country that they come
from or something but we thought as it's
a gaming episode what do you snack on
when you're gaming what what do you like
to eat and Chris says he liked these
gummy sour worms and they just happen to
be a favorite I mean Dom so here we are
we have trolley so we're breaks rollers
what about you bills when you're playing
League of Legends is there anything in
particular that you do like to snack on
because I think you have to be careful
with what you put your fingers on right
because if you're eating I like those
spicy chili pistachios but if you're
getting good right but if you're getting
that on your fingers and then you're
messing around with your mouse it's
gonna ruin it so for me I like maybe a
can of Red Bull lovely to get me going
yep and Route sponsor of Worlds 2022 I
got you BD team
maybe I walk away with a couple of cans
of Red Bull you say yeah there you go
also proud sponsor of the LCS I'm going
to cover the Red Bull team everything
brilliant what's up Red Bull team and
you know me I like an apple or you love
an oven Apple me very underrated fruit
because it's quite it's quite a long
game you know so if you play three games
I find myself getting quite hungry I
have to nip away and get I like cookies
I'll eat cookies cookies cookies also
Billy's got a tiny little dog hey uh not
a euphemism carry on
and um you like to have your dog at your
foot don't you well would you please
like sat right next on my feet there
right I'm gonna hand a few of these out
to the front row unfortunately the back
row have been absolutely scuppered here
I mean we could throw them but it could
be
is that okay
I think I think hygienically it's not
great
hold on
I can't throw that fast here
oh close-up
treat yourself all right we're sitting
back down nice then Chris lovely that
the great these there you go
there you go
there you go
there you go
hey we've gotta keep some for ourselves
now yeah come on John we did learn a
little bit about
um trolley the company that makes these
which kind of interesting Chris so
trolley
used to make pasta
yeah they're an Italian company it's uh
what no they're a German government
confuse me but they used to make pasta
in Germany during the second World War I
see the jump you made yeah
during the second world war obviously
there was a sugar shortage
um so they continue to make pasta and
then as they came out the second world
war there was a a massive influx of
sugar and the Pasta Company said why
don't we try and make sugary sweets the
same kind of shape as our pasta
voila which is French so messed that up
yeah all over
sour gummy worms and they're absolutely
delicious did anyone catch any yeah
what did people like when people are
eating uh playing League of Legends do
you eat something do you have a snack
he's he's he's saying no he's like no
it's not the same to snack
I like to get pumped up like an espresso
shot or half a can of Red Bull does
anyone do anything like that get fired
up
seven years
six to seven beers I like that shout and
you're often on my team aren't you
we've actually I've actually played a
couple of Tipsy games haven't we we've
specifically said let's go home get
slightly drunk and play League of
Legends because then you won't care as
much
it's fun that's been some of my favorite
games actually yeah you know a bottle of
wine yeah hello and then it all gets
quite relaxing then and then when people
are saying to me burn your computer
never play this game I'm like I'm okay
with that
so I had a I had a bad wine incident uh
oh no so I wasn't playing uh League of
Legends I was actually uh playing World
of Warcraft I was writing in World of
Warcraft
so blizzard and I spilled uh I spilled
my glass of red wine across my keyboard
oh no in the middle of a raid oh in the
middle right so I had nine people
waiting on me because it was back when
you rated 10.
um and I worked down the block from
where I lived in New York City uh so
everyone took a 15 minute break I ran
down the block to my office and took the
keyboard off my desk and then ran back
home and then we finished the raid nice
what as a result I no longer I no longer
drink anything that can spill into my
keyboard
one of those camo bags just fell away
yeah yeah that's a great idea well my
top tip which isn't really that much of
a top tip I keep all of my liquids on
the floor huh yeah so I've got my desk
here and I'm playing and my kind of Red
Bull is here away from my feet on the
floor I'm gonna drink it under the table
and then I come back there's no chance
it's gonna get anywhere near here I
didn't know you did that yeah that's
what I do but my dog's down there don't
drink him right
now tell us the story about your journey
with um sour gummy sweeties and why you
like them so much yeah so I uh when I
was in high school I had a buddy who was
really in a Sour Patch Kids so he had
them everywhere so you'd go to his house
to watch a movie and there were just
always Sour Patch Kids around uh when I
got to college uh I missed Sour Patch
Kids because I didn't have didn't have
my buddy around anymore uh so I went
down I went to college in Pennsylvania
I went down to the Wawa down on the
corner and uh yeah shout out to Wawa
um what's up come sponsor League of
Legends yeah and I uh I couldn't find
Sour Patch Kids but I found gummy worms
uh and I realized I like them a lot
better and I I was I was gonna I was
gonna say I like sour patch kids but I
grew up in Germany where the sour sweets
are no [ __ ] joke they take them very
seriously and they're very a good
consistency they don't taste the
chemicals the case The Taste the fruit
when I came over to yeah when I came up
to the states I was introduced to South
Africa's and I was like oh these are
great they're new they're fun it loses
the sour a little too quick for me and
it's a bit too jelly I want a little bit
of bite yeah it's gotta fight back a
little bit it's Gotta Fight Back like
gin
um but these are one of the these are
one of the Comfort things for Billy and
I when we when we go traveling and we're
out and about together if one of us is
losing a little bit of our energy yeah
it's our sweet to each other and I think
it's a good snack for video gaming so
that's good no we we always mark them
out at 10. I'll get Jenna wants some
more
on you go I'll carry on there's there's
three ways that we Mark the food
one taste what out of ten you're allowed
to use uh decimal points
also how it looks the aesthetic of the
food and also how useful is it how
useful huh so we will start with taste
taste or flavor
out of ten and what what are we like
objectively against any other food any
other game yeah just sharing this too
yes anything that you've ever tasted in
your life
Jesus
what is this out of ten as compared to
the best thing I've ever had in my life
yeah
six points and a half well you're quite
strict aren't you that's all right
that's good I mean you're comparing it
to the best thing I've ever tasted in my
whole life yeah I'm trying well we've
got the best scale the best thing I ever
tasted
there was that no I'll leave that for
another time
um I'm gonna give it
I'll give it a seven Seven's all right
it's not my favorite sour sweet but it's
a good one I think it's pretty tasty
I'll give it an 8.2 oh you love it
how does it look dumb well I think this
is where it's gonna get high scores
because I've eaten all my not only does
the sour uh wormy thing look good but
the bag looks good as well and
I don't know if you guys are aware of a
show that you can watch all of on
YouTube but if you've not seen it you
absolutely should because it's
incredible it's called Don't Hug Me I'm
Scared does anyone know that show
nice so the the genius behind that show
is a lady called Becky Sloan and Becky
Sloan does all of the advertising and
design work for trolley nowadays so all
the adverts that you see everything that
you see on TV everything that you see
online it's all Becky Sloan so I think
you know she's kind of
very cool
slightly otherworldly yeah and the
snakes themselves are good I'm giving it
a 9.3 you can use decimal points
I will give her a 7.8
okay dress over to you it kind of
reminds me a little bit of the LEC
broadcast colors like very neon yeah uh
and I I think that's all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna go just a flat eight eight
quite good all right now Billy's
favorite category that he came up with
usefulness how useful is this beautiful
is it say for instance someone came
around your house and they were looking
for something to eat
and all you had was this
three eggs in the fridge
maybe some flowers yeah
maybe some chocolate pieces I mean could
you make it into something else could
you grind it down and put any ice cream
for instance yeah well if you mean could
you cut it up and make a soup yeah if
you're meeting friends at a park and
you've forgotten to bring the sandwiches
if you bring these would they be happy
with it can you bring it to a sporting
event how would you use it could the
guys in between games two and three
could you say the guys here have a
couple of sweeties this will make you
feel good
huh yeah yeah can you do ice cream
flavors can you make it into a cake yeah
ice cream flavor I can see chop it up
maybe you use it as an ice cream topping
but yeah get out of that world I'm just
not sure hey it's a nice Halloween tree
right a trick-or-treating treat that's
not how that works you can't put open
Candy into little kids beds oh I do that
all the time oh yeah that stuff always
in the garbage my my house if you come
around trick or treat and it's open
Candy it's Tangerine pieces and it's
tiny fragments of coal and that's awful
that's all you get hey they won't come
back next year but my my favorite is the
people who are worried that uh people
are lacing candy with drugs yeah like do
you know how expensive drugs are yeah
yeah right yeah that's silly
um could you use the the gummy snakes to
kind of help someone I don't know if
they lose their footing on a on a on a
slight gradient could you say it grab
the end of that yeah if you tied them
together yeah that see Chris so yeah so
you gotta think outside the box you know
my outside the box thinking may not just
may not be up to Snuff for usefulness I
just think I'm gonna go with like a two
and a half two and a half yeah I would
say it's other than as a as a snack it's
not a very useful food thing is it I'll
I'm going to give up
because you can put it in ice cream and
improve ice cream
I'm going to give out a 4.2
I'd like to see it on top of a cake a
trolley sour gummy cake I'd like to see
it as different ice cream flavors
apart from that I do think it's quite
limited I'll be kind I'll give it a 3.5
not bad not bad scores for the jelly
whatever they're called trolleys lovely
stuff thanks for bringing them Chris
Willian the sky is beginning to bruise
and we we must Abed because tomorrow's a
big day it's a big day we're gonna have
to get ready we could get asked to go on
and play yeah I'm substitute for faker
I don't know if you guys know that and
it could be an exclusive but Faker said
if he cracks a nail or you know uh bus
one of his um finger Paws right he said
I'm I'm going next and I'm gonna go mid
you me
which I'm pretty sure is is off meta but
what's that Yumi but we're gonna we're
gonna shock the system do you know what
I mean really throw them off you know if
you pick Yumi they will they will boo
you is that right that is the way it
works yeah
tomorrow so when they ban you me the
audience will cheer and when you pick
Yumi everyone will boo listen I'm not a
fan of Yumi anytime she shows up in my
game either but I would like to play her
it's a weird dichotomy you know
hey thanks a lot for hanging out we're
in the in the freezing cold San
Francisco hopefully we get a chance to
see all you guys tomorrow have an
incredible day at Worlds Chris thanks
for coming on stage with us thanks for
having me and uh enjoy it can't wait
till tomorrow enjoy the League of
Legends Final yes see you guys later
bye-bye
harmonize with
[Music]
Meister baby you're my
[Music]